That was a more difficult problem. If you got negative 3 or negative 1 5th,
congratulations. I would say that you have mastered absolute value equations.
Let's see how we got those answers. When I have two absolute values that are
equal to each other, I still have to make two cases. And the two cases for this
problem are going to be 3 x plus 2 equals, the first case is going to be exactly
what's inside the absolute value, which is 2 x minus 1. The second case, we keep
the left side of the equation the same and make the right-hand side of the
equation negative, so I have negative 2 x minus 1. Let's go ahead and solve
these. First I subtract 2 x from both sides. When I subtract 2 x from both
sides, I get x plus 2 equals negative 1. And when I subtract 2 from both sides,
I get x equals negative 3. So, there's one of my answers. we have to be a little
more careful here. I have negative parentheses, 2 x minus 1, which means
negative 1 times 2 x minus 1. Which means I need to distribute that negative
sign. Negative 1 times 2 x is negative 2 x, and negative 1 times negative 1 is
positive 1. From here, I'm going to add 2 x to both sides, which gives me 5 x
plus 2 equals 1. When I subtract 2 from both sides, I get 5 x equals negative 1.
Divide both sides by 5, and I get x equals negative 1 5th. That problem was more
difficult then a lot of the absolute value equations. So, if you got the answer
right, I'd say you've mastered absolute value equations. And, we're ready to
move on to absolute value inequalities.